(guttural vocalizing)
- [Melissa Cross] The
most powerful thing about
being a metal singer,
(guttural vocalizing)
is the complete release
(loud screaming)
of passion.
(guttural vocalizing)
(loud metal rock music)
I teach people how to scream
effectively without damage,
but I'm also a singing teacher.
(vocalizing harmonically)
My background is Shakespeare and opera.
(gentle vocalizing)
I got known for being a scream teacher
because I figured this out,
and I'm glad I did,
because everyone was trashing themselves.
Instead of going reh-ahh, I
want (guttural vocalizing)
(guttural vocalizing)
Most metal kids, before they get trained,
they think that the only way
that you can get that sound
is to feel that way, and that's dangerous
because if you feel that way
when you make that sound,
it hurts.
(guttural vocalizing)
Three, four, five, and release everything.
I teach them the least
amount of effort to do it,
and then they don't
trash their vocal chords.
(guttural harmonizing)
I want it seamless.
Metal is, like, has a certain behavior,
and it's about loyalty.
It's real.
(subdued metal rock music)